Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir müssen etwas korrigieren oder wir müssten eher sagen,
wir sind vielleicht missverstanden worden oder haben uns etwas missverständlich
ausgedrückt. Es geht darum...
Wir sagen kurz dazu, wir korrigieren, wir können heute leider deine Stimme nicht
korrigieren, du bist etwas angeschlagen.
Ich bin ein bisschen angeschlagen, ja. Aber davon lassen wir uns jetzt nicht
irritieren. Es ging darum, dass
wir sagten, wir wollen keine Politiker bei Anti-AfD-Demonstrationen sehen.
Bezogen uns dabei aber natürlich auf die Spitzenpolitiker, also diese Leute,
die man laufend im Fernsehen sieht,
die dann Interviews geben, in denen sie sagen, wir brauchen die Bezahlkarte
für Flüchtlinge, wir brauchen mehr Abschiebungen oder die sonst laufend als,
ja, das markiert sind, Was die Rechten allen nicht mögen, also dass man dann
sagt, ja das ist halt so die Elite,
die Medienelite und die Politikelite ist da zusammen.
Wenn die jetzt auch noch diese Demonstrationen okkupieren und plötzlich sagen,
ach so, hier sind so viele Menschen, das ist doch auch nicht nur ein wunderbares
Fest der Demokratie, sondern gibt doch eigentlich auch der Ampelkoalition Rückhalt oder so etwas.
Dann ist das ein völlig falsches Zeichen.
Wir sind aber nicht dafür, dass generell Menschen,
die ein Parteibuch haben oder die sich auf kommunaler Ebene engagieren politisch
in Parteien, in Ämtern, da sind wir nicht dagegen,
dass diese an Demonstrationen teilnehmen.
Das gehört selbstverständlich zur Gesellschaft dazu. zu.
Es ist genau, wie du sagtest und wir hatten ja auch eine, eigentlich finde ich,
ich habe es nochmal nachträglich angehört, verständliche Argumentation gemacht,
indem wir nämlich sagten, oder wir lasen ja das Interview und,
Von Matthias Quent, der argumentierte, wenn die Demonstrationen aussehen wie
auf staatlichem Befehl, heute ist 1.
Mai, jetzt gehen wir demonstrieren, wir wenden uns gegen die faschistischen
Auffallungen im Westen, bauen sogar eine Mauer dagegen und so weiter.
Wenn das aussieht, als wären die Menschen auf der Straße aufgrund staatlicher
Befehle, beispielsweise weil Ricarda Lange sagt, hier und Demogeld gibt es auch
noch, dann gehen sie schief. Dann sind sie kontraproduktiv in den ja leider
schon vergifteten Kommunikationskanälen der AfD.
Also muss man diesen Eindruck zu vermeiden versuchen und daher diese klare Trennung
politische Mandatsträger in den Parlamenten,
die dort die AfD auf eigene Weise stellen können und dann die Zivilgesellschaft
außerhalb der Parlamente,
ohne dass da ein großes Crossing stattfindet.
Und dann kamen diese Hinweise, also mehrfach in Mails.
Der Tenor war ungefähr, ohne unsere Kommunalpolitiker, die die Demos angemeldet
hätten, wäre gar niemand auf die Straße gegangen.
Und da würde ich sagen, das ist schon ein bisschen problematisch,
wenn die Zivilgesellschaft aus eigener Kraft keine Vereine, Organisationen oder
was auch immer mehr vorfindet, lokal, die sagt, wir melden jetzt die Demo an.
Sondern wenn das dann der Landkreis, der Stadtrat, wer auch immer da mit Mandat
und Abgeordnet sein sagt, okay, ich lade ein und dann geht man dahin.
Also dann ist es in diesem von Matthias Quent vorgetragenen Problem keine von
der Zivilgesellschaft getragene Veranstaltung, sondern eine politische.
Und ja, die Demonstration soll politisch sein, aber nicht politisch organisiert.
Und diese Trennschärfe, da halte ich für absolut relevant und wichtig und die
muss beachtet werden und die ist auf jeden Fall, ist diese Grenze überschritten,
wenn die aus Funk und Fernsehen bekannten Ampelpolitiker, also nicht nur Bundestagsmandatsträger,
sondern obendrein noch Regierungsmitglieder, Kabinettstisch,
Sitzinhaber, dort glauben,
sie könnten Punktsieger einfahren, indem sie so eine Art, ich führe die Demo-Zug an oder sowas.
Das ist dann kontraproduktiv. Dann sagt die AfD, seht ihr, das sind sie.
Und da muss man aufpassen.
Und sagt ja zugleich auch vielen, die mit der Ampel-Koalition nicht einverstanden
sind, ja, wenn ihr hier mitdemonstriert, dann seid ihr also für die Ampel und findet das alles toll.
Und ich meine, wir haben eine fürchterliche Woche hinter uns.
Wir haben diese Bezahlkarte, die für Flüchtlinge eingeführt wurde,
was ich gar nicht in dem Sinne erst mitbekommen hatte. Das war mal in der Debatte
und dann dachte ich, gut, das ist ein völlig kruder Vorschlag,
vermutlich irgendwo aus der CSU oder Freie Wähler.
Und plötzlich ist sie da und ich war davon ganz erschlagen.
Dann haben wir jetzt die FDP, die das Lieferkettengesetz auf europäischer Ebene
blockiert, was wirklich eine Schande ist.
Und dann haben wir auch nochmal, besonders hier an die FDP zu adressieren,
dass die Bahn nicht weiter ausgebaut wird,
dass man dort angeblich nicht genügend Gelder hat.
Also es gibt so viele Schreckensmeldungen gerade. Ich möchte überhaupt nicht
mit der Ampel an irgendeiner Demonstration gemeinsam teilnehmen.
Ja, diese Themenliste, die du aufgezogen hast. Also es gab schon oder gibt schon
immer mal Bezahlkarten. Mir hat letztens erst jemand erzählt, als ich noch so...
Auf zivilgesellschaftlicher Engagementbasis mich um Geflüchtete gekümmert habe,
die hier ankamen, haben die auch eine Bezahlkarte bekommen, aber das war immer
noch ein eigentlich nur Bargeld ersetzendes allgemeines Zahlungsmittel.
Diese neue Karte, die es da jetzt gibt, die also sagt, nur in dem Laden,
nur diese Güter, nur in diesem Radius und so weiter und so fort.
Da kann man sich ja schon quasi vorstellen, wie hier die Flüchtlinge wieder
das Einfallstor sind für eine.
Ach, Bürgergeld möchtest du haben? Okay, hier nimm diese Bezahlkarte.
Da kriegst du diese Windeln, diesen Zwieback und dieses Brot.
Guck gar nicht, was sonst noch bei Rewe zur Verfügung steht.
Wir quälen dich hier. Also wie Helena Steinhaus auf Twitter schrieb,
das soll den Menschen einfach das Leben schwer machen und zwar sinnloserweise,
nur um irgendwelche Leute, die irgendwo mal an einem Telefonanruf teilnahmen,
hallo hier Infratest-DiMAP, wie finden sie denn das, ja blöd,
nur um die sozusagen zu befriedigen.
Ganz dramatisch finde ich aber das von dir angesprochene FDP-Veto zum Lieferkettengesetz.
Wir haben über das deutsche Lieferkettengesetz gesprochen und da kommt übrigens
dieses Zitat her aus dieser Diskussion von dem ehemaligen Entwicklungsminister
CSU, Müller, der sagte, für uns arbeiten 50 Sklaven irgendwo auf der Welt.
Aber die Große Koalition hat sich es kurz und klein schlagen lassen.
CDUler standen im Bundestag, haben gesagt, das sollten wir nie machen,
die deutsche Wirtschaft in Ketten legen, während wir gleichzeitig Clips gehört
haben von Mercedes-Benz.
Da saßen wir und meinten, hä, wieso, darüber schließen wir doch den Markt.
Wenn diese Standards gelten, die wir schon einhalten, dann ist das doch gut für uns.
Also CDUler wussten damals in Regierungsverantwortung nicht,
was sie taten und die FDP und nach dem E-Fuels-Massaker damals,
ist das jetzt das zweite Mal, dass der EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess komplett durch war.
Nur noch die formale letzte, okay, der Gesetzgebungsprozess ist durch,
alle Argumente sind ausgetauscht, EU-Kommission hat einen Vorschlag gemacht,
EU-Rat hat sich dazu verhalten, Parlament auch, man hat einen Kompromiss im
Trilog ausgehandelt, das Ding ist fertig.
Und dann kommt die FDP und sagt, nein, also das ist auf doppelter,
methodischer und inhaltlicher Ebene einfach ein Skandal.
Und da ich auf Twitter zu diesem Thema schrieb, es ist eigentlich egal,
ob wir von der AfD oder von der FDP regiert werden, in dem Fall ist es wirklich egal.
Ja, das hätten die genauso gemacht. Genau.
Wenn wir eine menschenverachtende Politik der AfD befürchten,
weil da einfach heißt, wir wollen, dass Leute zur Remigration,
keine Ahnung, wir ihnen ein schlecht mögliches Lebensumfeld machen,
wir wollen sie richtig vertreiben und vergrämen.
Dann ist das ja eine Art von, okay, wir behandeln jetzt Menschen ganz schlecht,
damit wir was auch immer davon haben. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
wie ein ökonomischer oder gesellschaftlicher Benefit daraus kommen kann,
wenn 25 Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland abwandern.
Aber gut, andere Diskussion, wir haben darüber gesprochen.
Nur, die FDP ist auf Augenhöhe, was die Unmenschlichkeit angeht.
Und wer in Bangladesch siebenjährige Kinder in der Schneiderei sieht,
die für deutsche Kinder Sachen nähen, sagt einfach, nein, das darf es nicht geben.
Und wenn eine Partei sagt, na...
Damit kein zusätzlicher Bürokratismus entsteht, soll es das doch geben,
dann ist das AfD-Politik.
Dann ist das egal, ob uns die AfD regiert oder die FDP.
Das ist dann dasselbe in Sachen Menschenverachtung. Und von daher ist das,
was die Ampel da gerade fabriziert und dass niemand von den anderen beiden Parteien
auch nur mal kurz erwähnt, wie sich die FDP da gerade verhält, ist ein Skandal.
Dafür würde ich den Bundeskanzler ehrlicherweise zurücktreten lassen,
wenn es nach mir ginge. Es.
Gibt ja immerhin noch die SPD
und die Grünen. Man hört von ihnen nichts in puncto Lieferkettengesetz.
Man kann irgendwo was suchen gehen. Vielleicht wird jetzt irgendjemand einen
Abgeordneten kennen, der was wohl gesagt hat. Aber es ist überhaupt nicht Debatte.
Es ist ohnehin nur im Deutschlandfunk oder so nachvollziehbar ein bisschen in
der Printpresse. Aber sonst ist das nicht das große Fernsehthema.
Müsste es aber eigentlich sein.
Müsste man eigentlich auch, weil man ja jetzt gerade wieder Strackzimmermann
jeden Tag in sieben Talkshows einlädt, das sein, worauf man sie anspricht.
Denn sie sagt ja, wir verteidigen hier Europa, Europas Zusammenhalt geht nur,
wenn wir gemeinsam ganz, ganz viel aufrüsten gegen die bösen Autokraten dieser Welt.
Da müsste man mal fragen, was das eigentlich für eine Vorstellung von Welt ist,
in der wir dann aber als Industrieland weiterhin Kinderarbeit und alles zulassen
und uns aber dann beschweren, wenn irgendwelche anderen Autokraten sich nicht
so gut gegenüber ihrer Bevölkerung verhalten.
Und dann sagen die, naja, ihr beutet die ja sowieso aus, dann können wir das auch machen.
Und es gab ja, wie du jetzt gerade schon sagtest, etwas, wo man sehen konnte,
es gibt noch so etwas wie eine europäische Einheit, die jetzt von Deutschland
durch die FDP zerschlagen wird.
Also wenn man wirklich an einer europäischen Einheit interessiert wäre,
was Strackzimmermann natürlich nicht ist, sondern nur vorgibt,
um diese Rüstungsausgaben zu erhöhen, dann müsste man ja gerade für dieses Lieferkettengesetz sein.
Mhm.
Zum Thema Agnes Strack-Zimmermann. Wolfgang Streeck hat in der Frankfurter Rundschau,
glaube ich, einen Text über die Nibelungentreue Deutschlands geschrieben,
in dem Strack-Zimmermann nicht zu Wort kommt, sondern thematisiert wird.
Also diesem Urteil schließe ich mich einfach komplett an, das ist alles so Banane,
was man da sieht. Den Text müsste man erst diskutieren und so weiter.
Ich habe ihn heute nicht dabei, er kam erst heute Morgen, aber die Anmerkungen
zu Strackzimmermann, der Rolle
der Verantwortung und der inhaltlichen Äußerungen würde ich sagen. Ja.
Der ist zuzustimmen.
Da kann man mal zustimmen, genau. Genau. So.
Ich möchte noch gerade auf etwas hinweisen, nämlich ich mache Werbung in eigener
Sache jetzt, aber du kannst natürlich auch kommen oder ich weiß, dass du kommen wirst.
Ich bin ja jetzt mit Ole und Jean-Philippe auf der Bühne.
Aber in Hannover? Das ist zu weit für mich.
Ja, am 9. Februar bin ich in Hannover. Also wer da noch kommen will,
es gibt noch Karten. Am 27.
Februar sind wir in Leipzig. Und am 2. März, aber Stefan, da sind wir in Frankfurt.
Und da bist du dann hoffentlich auch dabei. Wir reservieren dir einen schönen Platz.
Sehr gut. 2. März?
2. März. Und wer jetzt das genauer nachvollziehen will, geht einfach auf meine
Homepage oder auf Jean-Philipps Instagram-Seite. Da findet man alles.
Sehr gut. Kindler stößt an oder so heißt das Format, ne?
Genau.
Sehr gut. Unterstütze ich, ich stoße dann auch mit an.
Wir besprechen heute ein Buch von einem Autor, der kein Deutscher ist,
weshalb wir unsicher sind darüber, wie sein Name auszusprechen ist.
Ich würde sagen, Rutger Bregmann, aber das Internet sagt Rutger Bergmann, Rutger Bregmann.
Rutger Bregmann oder so etwas.
Ich glaube, wir machen es uns einfach und erlauben uns, Bregmann zu sagen. Ja.
Wir sagen Bregmann oder der Autor. Oder, nee, da muss man ja nicht gendern,
man weiß ja, wen man meint.
Wir besprechen heute dieses Buch, es heißt im Grunde gut.
Und haben ja beim letzten Mal, als ich das Buch noch nicht las,
gesagt, ah schade, die Jeff Bezos Clips müssen wir eigentlich noch spielen und
nicht in der fünften Stunde des Podcasts, wo alle schon müde sind,
sondern nochmal frisch.
Und sie passen erstaunlicherweise wie die Faust aufs Auge zur Besprechung dieses
Buches nachher, das ja als These hat, wir folgen dem falschen Menschenbild.
Eigentlich sollten wir mehr von uns selbst ausgehen.
Wir selber halten uns für gute Menschen, also sind die anderen wahrscheinlich
auch gut. Gut, sie würden uns nicht mit Absicht mit ihrem 3-Tonnen-SUV überrollen,
sondern einfach an uns vorbeifahren, auch wenn es Spaß machen würde, uns zu crashen.
Und wir stellen ja fest, wir werden recht selten überfahren,
also scheint was dran zu sein an der These.
Ob die Argumentation im Buch klüger ist als das, was ich gerade sagte,
klären wir nachher. Ja, wir kommen zu Jeff Bezos.
Der war also im Interview bei Lex Friedman. Wir haben den Podcast schon ein
paar Mal angesprochen, weil er immer diese ganzen Silicon Valley Größen bei sich hat.
Und wir gucken mal zehn Clips von sehr vielen mehr.
Also wir werden noch ein paar Mal auf dieses Bezos Gespräch zurückkommen,
auch weil es eins der wenigen ist, dass es gibt.
Also dass er über zwei Stunden irgendwo rumsitzt.
Ich kann mich nicht an ein anderes
erinnern. Also kriegen wir hier einen seltenen Einblick in sein Tun.
Bezos ist als reichster Mensch der Welt natürlich, man muss ihm jetzt unterstellen,
dass er eine praktische Intelligenz hat, die beispiellos ist, würde ich sagen.
Also er hat es geschafft, dieses Geld irgendwie auf seine Seite zu ziehen mit
Entscheidungen. Und in Brickmanns Buch geht es ja auch um Entscheidungen,
wie treffen wir eigentlich Entscheidungen und so weiter.
Nach welchen Richtlinien, Orientierungen Nordsternen.
Und wir lernen im Brickmanns Buch, wir sind soziale Wesen.
Schimpansen, diese eine Pointe fand ich ja ganz interessant,
Schimpansen sind mit zweijährigen Kindern gleichauf,
aber sie orientieren sich nicht aneinander, sondern jedes Schimpansenwesen,
muss man fast sagen, lebt für sich, während Kinder nur nach Vorbild lernen, die ganze Zeit.
Er macht dann so einen Faktor 100 Unterschied, wenn man es operationalisiert
nach irgendwelchen, wir gucken jetzt mal, wie sozial die Kinder sind,
dann bleiben die Schimpansen einfach bei 0 und die Kinder schlagen so auf Skala
Wert 100 an in diesem Test und das ist ja schon beachtlich.
Wir sind also soziale Wesen, müssen uns miteinander koordinieren und wollen
aber gleichzeitig kluge Entscheidungen treffen. Wie geht denn das eigentlich?
Und dazu hier Anmerkungen von Jeff Bezos. Zum Ersten, zu Beginn, der Kompromiss.
Wir hatten 70 Jahre Grundgesetzfeier mit einer großen Ausstellung im Historischen
oder Deutschen Museum oder wie auch immer da in Bonn. Der Kompromiss.
Der Parlamentarismus lebt von der Regierung-Kompositionsunterscheidung,
aber vor allem auch vom Kompromiss, was ja umso wichtiger wird,
wenn nicht nur zwei, sondern drei Parteien koalieren, also eine Regierung bilden
und dann noch eine Opposition daneben.
Und die Opposition sich auch uneins ist und so weiter, dann steht nichts über
dem Kompromiss. Das ist die historische Erfahrung.
Und Jeff Bezos blickt jetzt nicht in die Parlamente, sondern in seine Vorstandsriegen.
Management-Entscheidungen müssen getroffen werden. Welchen Wert hat eigentlich der Kompromiss?
Der Kompromiss ist eine andere Entscheidungsfindung als Wahrheit zu finden,
wenn man weiß, dass eine Suche nach Wissen zur Wahrheit führt.
Und das finde ich super interessant unter der Maßgabe, dass wir ja zum Beispiel
jetzt eine neue Talkshow haben oder zwei neue Talkshows.
Also Hard Aber Fair hat gerade seinen Modus geändert. und wir haben eine neue
Moderatorin mit Karin Miosga.
Wir unterstellen jetzt, okay, da sitzen Politiker, die diskutieren jetzt dort
so, wie sie im Parlament diskutieren.
Sie sind also auf Kompromisssuche.
Und relativ häufig haben wir ja es mit Fragen zu tun, bei denen wir keinen Kompromiss,
sondern eine Aufklärung brauchen. brauchen.
Bürgergeldempfänger kriegen zu viel. Der Lohnabstand zum Mindestlohn ist zu
gering oder wie auch immer.
Ist das eigentlich eine Frage, bei der wir einen Kompromiss suchen müssen oder
bei der wir auch einfach mal, ja ist denn der Abstand zu klein oder wie auch immer.
Also haben wir eigentlich mit einer Wissensfrage zu tun, bei der der Kompromiss,
der klügeren Entscheidung im Wege steht.
Diese Frage ist seine Lebensfrage. Wie organisiere ich meinen Laden so,
dass ich zu einer klugen, wissensbasierten Entscheidung komme,
die meinen Laden nach vorne bringt, auf Kosten des Kompromisses.
Ja, Karl Lagerfeld ist ja nun jemand, der nie ein Unternehmen selbst besessen hat,
sondern immer nur Angestellter war, wie er sagte, aber er konnte dort natürlich alles machen,
also bei Chloé und dann vor allem ja bei Chanel und er hat bei Chanel sicherlich
die größte Narrenfreiheit gehabt und hat dort aber gesagt, dass er nie diskutiert hat.
Also er hat sich vorher etwas überlegt und dann wurde das umgesetzt und es musste
auch gar nicht diskutiert werden, sagte er, weil er ja vorher nachgedacht hat.
Das heißt also, das ist die absolute Negierung von Kompromiss,
sondern einer trifft die Entscheidung und er sagte dann aber auch,
er bezog sich dann auf Spinoza, Außer, jede Entscheidung ist Verneinung,
das heißt also, wenn man eine Entscheidung trifft, fallen ganz viele Optionen selbstredend weg.
Genau.
Und das ist in diesem Fall dann Jeff Bezos.
Ganz genau. Das ist nämlich die zweite Kategorie, die hier zur Geltung kommt.
Wenn man an einem Kabinettstisch sitzt und man möchte eine Einheit,
also die wollen ja immer eine Einstimmigkeit, aber man will ein mehrheitliches
herbeigeführtes Ergebnis,
man macht also Kompromisse, Kuhhandel und so weiter, man sagt dann heute stimme
ich für dich, morgen stimmst du dann für mich, wie auch immer,
das steht einer Truth-Seeking-Entscheidung im Wege.
Wenn man jetzt nicht zu einem Kompromiss kommt, also es fehlen Daten und man
kriegt niemanden überzeugt, dann sollte man den Vorteil nutzen,
in eine Hierarchie ausweichen zu können.
I try to ask people who, you know, on my team, I say, never get to a point where
you are resolving something by, you know, who gets exhausted first.
Escalate that. I'll help you make the decision. Because that's so de-energizing
and such a terrible, lousy way to make a decision.
Do you want to get to the resolution as quickly as possible because that ultimately
leads to a high velocity?
Also.
Es gibt mehrere knappe Ressourcen, Zeit und Informationsstand.
Man kann mehr Informationen holen, kostet aber mehr Zeit, wie auch immer.
Muss man das überhaupt? Ist die Entscheidung so wichtig? Da muss man dann abwägen.
Diese Ermüdungsstrategie ist niemals gut.
Der einzige Fall, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, okay, ist so Angela Merkel verhandelt
im EU-Rat und es wird die Nacht sitzen.
Ja, da kommen wir auch gerade ein, ja, ja.
Es gibt keine höhere Hierarchiestufe. Es muss in diesem Raum entschieden werden.
Da würde ich sagen, ja gut, wenn man von sich glaubt, man hält am besten durch,
kann man diese Karte spielen.
Aber die ist natürlich sehr leistungsfähig.
Insgesamt wird das soziale System und die Entscheidungsfindung bezogen, ist das nicht.
Nur ist man ja auch in dieser politischen Sphäre nicht unbedingt evidenzbasiert
unterwegs, sondern man ist machtorientiert.
Also man will entweder die Macht haben oder kämpft dafür, sie zu haben.
Und das bedeutet dann, dass man sich eine Strategie ausdenkt,
wie man diese Macht erlangt. Und das kann dann durchhaltend sein.
Aber das führt natürlich in einem Unternehmen nicht unbedingt.
Also das mag dem Einzelnen im Unternehmen, in der Hierarchie dann dazu verhelfen, aufzusteigen.
Aber dem Unternehmen als Ganzes, also dass es profitabler ist,
besser produziert etc., hilft es dann nicht.
Ja, deswegen müssen wir bei so einer Feststellung wie im Grunde sind wir gut, uns wirklich fragen,
Im Rahmen welcher Zielsetzung? Einer einheitlichen Vernunft,
also wir sind eigentlich gut, sollte doch das große Ganze auch gut sein,
wenn wir aber konkurrierende Rationalitäten haben.
Welche setzt sich denn dann durch? Welche ist denn dann erfolgsversprechend
für die meisten oder wie auch immer, wann das dann formuliert ist,
dieses, ja aber eigentlich ist der Einzelne doch gut.
Wie weit kann uns das denn in eine gute Richtung führen und ab wann stehen wir
uns denn da selbst im Weg?
Jeff Bezos als großer Unternehmenslenker, also wir können ja durchaus sagen,
Unternehmen sind nicht demokratisch aufgebaut, sondern da gibt es Entschädigungszahlungen dafür,
dass man sich unterwirft, kann natürlich da anders mit umgehen,
mit solchen Fragestellungen, als jetzt immer auf eine demokratische Grundlage
zurückgeworfen zu werden.
Von daher macht er hier auch mit all seiner Erfahrung die Unterscheidung mal
ganz deutlich, ganz explizit.
Wir sind soziale Tiere. Ja, wir sind. Und, weißt du, wenn du 10.000 Jahre zurückgehst
und in einem kleinen Dorf bist, wenn du hinweggehst, um hinzuzufahren,
kannst du überleben. Du kannst prokreatieren.
Wenn du der Dorf-Gewissheitsteller bist, kannst du in der Mitte der Nacht zu
Todesstunde verletzt werden.
Wahrheiten sind oft, sie wollen nicht gehört werden, weil wichtige Wahrheiten.
Unangenehm sind, sie können schmerzhaft sein, Sie können mühsam sein.
Unpolitisch. Ja, herausfordernd. Sie können Leute defensiv machen,
auch wenn das nicht der Intent ist.
Aber jede hochperformierte Organisation, ob es ein Sportteam,
ein Geschäft ist, eine politische Organisation, ein Aktivistgruppe,
ich weiß nicht, was es ist, jede hochperformierte Organisation,
Es muss Mechanismen und eine Kultur sein, die die Wahrheit sagt.
Eine der Dinge, die man tun muss, ist, dass man darüber sprechen muss.
Und man muss darüber sprechen, dass es Energie braucht, um das zu tun.
Und man muss Menschen sprechen, man muss Menschen erinnern, dass es okay ist, dass es ungeheuer ist.
Man muss literally sagen, dass es nicht das ist, was wir als Menschen geplant
sind. Es ist nicht wirklich, es ist ein Art Abweichung. You know,
we can do that. But it's not how we survive.
We mostly survive by being social animals and being cordial and cooperative.
And that's really important. And so there's a, you know, science is all about truth telling.
It's actually a very formal mechanism for trying to tell the truth.
And even in science, you find that it's hard to tell the truth.
Der ganze Wissenschaftsbetrieb, der darauf aufbaut, zu guten Entscheidungen zu führen.
Ich will jetzt nicht die Wissenschaft einer sozusagen handlanger Methode für
Entscheidungsfindung zu reduzieren,
aber der Wissenschaftsbetrieb hat schon erheblichen Beratungspotenzial für die
Gesellschaft, der gerne genutzt wird.
Überall. So, wir lesen gerne Ratgeber-Magazine, in denen wollen wir gezielt
was anderes drinstehen, als was uns Freundin Edi dazu erzählt,
egal welchen Problem. So.
Und das hat Wert für sich.
Und wenn man den aber expliziert, bedeutet das, wir haben dort,
der Ausgangspunkt ist, wir haben erkannt, wir sind soziale Wesen und wollen
uns jetzt dagegen stellen, bis hin zu dagegen wehren.
Denn der Ausgangspunkt, wir sind im Grunde gut, führt zwei Schritte weit.
Wir wollen aber zehn Schritte weit gehen.
Also muss man etwas opfern. Wir haben das diskutiert beim Thema effektiver Altruismus
oder dann auch Longterm-Müssen.
Unterschiedliche Konzepte, die zur Geltung kamen. Aber darf man in der Jetzt-Zeit...
Tatsächlich lebende Menschen opfern, um noch nicht Geborene,
aber deren Schicksal wird ja auch irgendwann geschrieben, sie haben nur den
Nachteil, erst in der Zukunft zur Geltung zu kommen, darf man heute Menschen
opfern, also weniger Menschen opfern, um es später vielen besser zu machen.
All solche Fragen, da würde man auf beiden Seiten irgendwie zu einer Argumentation
kommen, ja, das ist im Grunde gut.
Setzt sich für die Menschheit ein, für die spätere Menschheit,
opfert dafür die heutige und so weiter. Also man kommt aus diesem Dilemma niemals
raus, egal wie man argumentiert.
Die Feststellung, im Grunde gut, reicht also so und so weit,
wenn man ein Ziel erreichen möchte, und zwar für viele.
Und jetzt würde ich bei dem Thema Amazon sagen, ja, die Arbeitsbedingungen sind, wie sie sind.
Unsozial, aber dafür kamen dann ganz schön viele Menschen durch Lockdown und
Pandemie. Kann man das jetzt irgendwie miteinander aufwiegen?
Wie weit kommen wir jetzt mit einer Argumentation, in der das Grundsätzlich
Gute des Menschen irgendwie Geltung haben soll? –.
Naja, das ist doch gar nicht das Modell, das der Überlegung da zugrunde liegt von Jeff Bezos.
Also er sagt ja eher, dass er gegen dieses Soziale anarbeitet,
also dass Leute zum Herdentierverhalten neigen oder dass sie es sich nicht mit
jemandem verklemen wollen und dann nicken sie eher Dinge ab,
schauen lieber über die Wahrheit hinweg, bevor sie sich mit ihren Kollegen auf
einen Disput einlassen.
Ich glaube, dass das ein Mechanismus ist, den alle kennen aus Vereinen oder aus dem Arbeitsumfeld.
Zugleich frage ich mich, wann hat zum letzten Mal irgendjemand Jeff Bezos die Wahrheit gesagt?
Also wann hat er zum letzten Mal von irgendjemandem gesagt bekommen,
das ist ja vollkommen Unsinn, den du da machst oder lass das doch.
Wird es da noch Leute geben? Außer jetzt, dass irgendwelche Finanzberater sagen,
ziehen sie mal lieber noch fünf Milliarden rüber zu MSCI World und vergessen
sie die Immobilien in Hongkong oder so.
Aber wird es sonst noch irgendjemand geben, der zu ihm die Wahrheit spricht?
Da wäre ich schon sehr skeptisch. Und dann bringt ja diese Hierarchie in einem
Unternehmen es mit sich,
dass man also die Möglichkeit haben muss aufzusteigen und dieses Aufsteigen
funktioniert ja sehr stark durch das Schmeicheln.
Also es gibt natürlich, wir kennen das alles aus Filmen, diese Fälle,
wo einer dem Vorgesetzten widerspricht und dieser Vorgesetzte dann so weitsichtig ist,
dass er aufgrund dieses Widerspruchs das Potenzial seines Untergebenen erkennt.
Aber das kann man sicherlich auch noch mehr herausarbeiten in der Managementtheorie
oder in der Unternehmensberatung, dass diese Mechanismen besser wirken und dass
das nicht gleich Sanktionierung von oben nach unten bedeutet.
Aber das sind eher seltene Fälle, glaube ich.
Sonst ist, glaube ich, dieses Wesen des Schmeichelns oder des Füßeküssens,
was man eigentlich aus der höfischen Gesellschaft kennt,
etwas, was wir auch in den modernen Unternehmen nach wie vor so vorfinden können.
Wir haben es jetzt natürlich nur mit massenmedialen Kommunikation zu tun.
Wir sehen hier Jeff Bezos abgebildet. Wir erleben ihn nicht als Privatmann,
nicht unmittelbar, wie auch immer.
Trotzdem ist das ja die interessanteste Frage. Traut sich noch jemand Jeff Bezos
zu widersprechen, wenn er glaubt, er hätte eine gute Idee?
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal aus, auch wenn ich so Scott Galloway zuhöre,
also das sind ja Leute, die verdienen ja Millionen und Millionen.
Und jetzt gibt es ja zwei verschiedene Herangehensweisen.
Entweder wie Mark Zuckerberg, also der hat jetzt letzten Quartalszahlen vorgelegt
und alle waren so ein bisschen überrascht, wie das Board sich da verhält.
Also da kriegt einfach, also das Board kriegt hunderte Millionen an Geldern
einfach ausgezahlt, dafür, dass sie da im Board sind, wo jeder weiß,
Ah ja, das ist, damit man finanziell abhängig davon ist, was Mark Zuckerberg entscheidet.
Das sind Hochschranzchen. Genau.
Also lässt sich da gar nicht diese Larry Ellison und so, das sind ja Leute,
also das sind dann so Stiefel-Lecker-Konglomerate, die da zur Geltung kommen.
Und dann gibt es aber Gegenmodelle wie Scott Galloway, der halt aktiv Leute
bezahlt dafür, dass sie ihm widersprechen. Der sagt halt, du kennst jetzt meine
Meinung, ich will jetzt nicht nochmal meine Meinung hören, sondern ich bezahle
dich dafür, eine andere Meinung zu hören.
Das lässt sich auch institutionalisieren. Man muss es ja nicht immer auf,
hat schon mal jemand Jeff Bezos sich getraut zu kränken.
Darum geht es ja nicht, sondern es geht ja darum, in einer Sitzung,
in einem Meeting da zu sitzen, seine Meinung zu kennen und trotzdem...
Eine andere Meinung zu äußern. Und das kann man durchaus auch mit Anreizen organisieren.
Er selber reflektiert dieses Problem auch und löst es wie folgt.
Kann overrule the most senior person if they have data and that really is about
trying to you know, there are little things you can do.
So for example, in every meeting that I attend, I always speak last.
Das kenne ich aus eigener Erfahrung, wenn der Chefe anwesend ist und zuhört
und sagt, ich bin hier, um zuzuhören.
Ihr müsst jetzt was Interessantes sagen, ohne meine Meinung zu kennen.
Kommt man gar nicht umhin, dass man eine andere Meinung äußert, als der Chefer hat.
Und man erfährt sie am Ende auch. Und dann, klar, macht man sich Gedanken,
man kommt aus der Schleife nicht raus.
Trotzdem wird man gerade dafür bezahlt, Sachen zu sagen, ohne zu wissen,
in welche Richtung sich der Raum hier gerade bewegt.
Also man kann dann nicht sozialkonform antworten oder sich äußern und muss sich
trotzdem deutlich äußern.
Also wenn man dann nicht entschieden eine Meinung vertritt, weiß man auch,
ich mache hier gerade was falsch. Das ist ist auch nicht der richtige Weg.
Also man kann das schon provozieren, auch mit solchen Leuten anwesend,
dass es dann nochmal hinhaut.
Es ist der Dezisionismus, also die Entscheidungs-, nicht nur Entscheidungsfreude,
sondern habe eine starke Entscheidung und kämpfe sie auch durch. Es gibt einige.
Auch organisierte und von der Hierarchie dann fast unberührte Möglichkeiten
zu sagen, hier werden bitte starke Meinungen geäußert, auch ins Blaue hinein.
Also das lässt sich schon institutionalisieren, so wie ich ihn hier verstehe,
hat er genau darauf immer Wert gelegt.
Because we really do. We actually literally change our opinions.
If somebody who you really respect says something, it makes you change your mind a little.
So you're saying, implicitly or explicitly give permission for people to have
a strong opinion, as long as it's backed by data.
Yes, and sometimes it can even, by the way, a lot of our most powerful truths
turn out to be hunches. They turn out to be based on anecdotes,
they're intuition-based, and sometimes you don't even have strong data.
But you may know the person well enough to trust their judgment,
you may feel yourself leaning in, it may resonate with a set of anecdotes you
have, and then you may be able to say, you know, something about that feels right.
Let's go collect some data on that.
Hier diese Abwägung zu machen, wir brauchen eine Entscheidung.
Wir haben zu wenig Zeit und zu wenig Wissen. Wir können jetzt Zeit gegen Wissen
aufwiegen, also Recherche kostet Zeit.
Gleichzeitig ist es eine Teamarbeit. Wir sind soziale Wesen,
wollen aber am Ende, dass auch Prinzipien zur Geltung kommen,
die gerade nicht darauf abstellen, dass wir soziale Wesen sind,
also den Kompromiss vermeiden und so weiter und so fort und da eine Abwägung zu treffen.
Deswegen ja auch Managementmoden, weil man genau weiß, wir führen das jetzt
ein, aber nach einem Jahr müssen wir es ändern.
Auch wenn es erfolgreich war, weil es sich dann eingeschliffen hat,
wie auch immer, dann kommen wieder Sachen zur Geltung, dann müssen wir sie ändern,
dann kommt die Reform, dann sagt Luhmann, die Reform ist nicht dafür da,
Neues einzuführen, sondern erstmal das Alte zu vergessen.
Vergessen, dann dreht man drei, vier Runden und dann im siebten Jahr kann man
wieder mit der ersten Mode anfangen, wenn sie alle möglichst vergessen haben
und auch neues Personal da ist und so weiter und dann dreht sich das immer im
Kreis, aber man kann nicht einfach reinkommen und sagen,
aber im Grunde sind wir gut, weil dann fehlt so dieses,
ja, aber im Grunde leben wir auch in einer großen Gesellschaft,
im Grunde sind wir einzelne im direkten Umgang miteinander gut,
ja, aber das große Bild wird dann ausgeblendet und dann könnte man genauso mit
dem großen Bild anfangen und sagen, ja, aber eigentlich sind wir ja ganz anders.
Dann schreibt man wieder ein Buch, im Grunde gut.
Ja, also es, wie soll ich sagen, es gibt da keinen archimedischen Punkt.
Es gibt da keine, das ist die These, mit der wir ab jetzt durch die Welt gehen und so weiter.
Sondern es sind Zyklen, ausgeprägt in Moden,
Aber.
Kann man überhaupt diese Prämisse, im Grunde sind wir gut, anlegen auf ein Unternehmen,
das überhaupt nicht die Prämisse hat, die Welt zu verbessern?
Also das mag ein schöner Side-Effekt sein und du hast das jetzt eben ausgeführt mit der Pandemie.
Wir wurden alle gut von Amazon versorgt, aber das war ja nicht die Idee hinter
dem Unternehmen, dass man sagt, wir errichten da mal etwas, wenn eine schlimme
Pandemie kommt, werden wir die Leute versorgen können.
Sondern das ist ja ein Unternehmen, das auf Expansion und auf Profit aus ist
und das gelingt ihm auch ganz erstaunlich.
Und über so viele Jahre hinweg und mit immer neuen Bereichen,
in denen man sehr, sehr erfolgreich ist.
Denken wir nur an die AWS-Sparte, die extrem erfolgreich bei Amazon ist oder auch der Marketplace.
Aber da ist ja jetzt so eine Anthropologie,
die uns angeboten wird von Bregmann, etwas, was dem noch nicht mal widerspricht,
sondern wo man eher sich fragen kann, hat das eine mit dem anderen überhaupt irgendetwas zu tun?
Also das ist für mich fast so wie zu sagen, im Grunde wollen wir alle gesund sein.
Das ist auch so, aber das hilft mir jetzt nicht weiter, wenn ich morgen ein
Medienunternehmen oder ein Versandhaus leiten muss.
Also ich kann das jetzt ganz partiell dann vielleicht sagen,
ja wir müssen ein bisschen investieren in Sicherheit, damit alle gesund bleiben,
damit niemand verletzt wird im Betrieb oder so etwas,
aber das ist nicht in dem Sinne handlungsleitend, deswegen glaube ich und darüber
müssen wir nachher diskutieren bei dem Prägmann, im Prinzip ist es ein ganz radikales Buch.
Ich glaube nur, dass der Autor seine eigene Radikalität noch nicht begriffen hat.
Aber das kommt später. Was ich hier bei Bezos beeindruckend finde,
ist dieses strukturierte Sprechen.
Also man bekommt einen Eindruck davon, wie offenbar dieses Unternehmen geführt
wird und jetzt werden manche sicherlich sagen, ja aber Amazon,
ihr müsst doch jetzt mal thematisieren, haben wir alles getan,
wir haben über ausgeliefert gesprochen,
dieses Buch kann man im Salon nochmal nachhören, wir sind keine blinden Amazon Verehrer.
Was man aber, glaube ich, hier herausstellen kann, ist, dass jemand ein unglaubliches
Organisationstalent hat.
Und dies ist etwas, was mich auch immer wieder beeindruckt, da man ja in verschiedenen
Zusammenhängen mit Leuten zu tun hat.
Und man merkt relativ schnell, mit wem man etwas machen kann oder nicht.
Also Leute, die organisiert sind oder nicht.
Und dann frage ich mich manchmal, woran es liegt, dass es bei anderen so wenig funktioniert.
Und ich glaube, es gibt so eine ganz große Idee und das ist wahrscheinlich dieses
soziale Gegen, dass man arbeiten muss und womit man aber nicht asozial ist,
dass man glaubt, je mehr man über etwas redet, desto besser ist das.
Also manchmal bekommt man auch Anfragen, soll einen kleinen Artikel schreiben
und soll aber erst noch zwei Stunden vorher konferieren, wo ich dann denke, ja, aber warum?
Ich würde den einfach mal schreiben, den Artikel und wenn es dann noch Fragen
gibt, können wir die ja kurz klären.
Aber das ist bei vielen unglaublich ausgeprägt, dass man glaubt,
je mehr Worte gesprochen werden,
desto klarer wird am Ende alles, desto besser ist es für alle,
aber das Gegenteil ist oft der Fall.
Also, zu deiner Frage, hängt das miteinander zusammen? Da würde ich sagen,
alles, also hier hängt wirklich alles mit allem zusammen.
Und ich verknüpfe diese Bezos-Sachen hier, und ich finde es auch nur deswegen
interessant, das mit dem Buch zu verknüpfen, weil viele unserer Hörer uns ja
schrieben, dass sie das Buch schon kennen und schätzen und so weiter und so
fort. Und wir schauen natürlich erst im Salon in den Text rein.
Aber ich habe jetzt ja den Titel ja schon mehrfach genannt.
Und ich finde, auf dem Buchtitel zu schreiben, im Grunde gut.
Also im Grunde sind wir vieles. Wir leben zu ungesund oder wie auch immer.
Also das, was du angesprochen hast, wir könnten auch gesünder leben.
Also im Grunde ungesund.
Dieses Gut ist ja ein ganz gefährliches Wort, weil auf der anderen Seite der
Unterscheidung schlecht steht. Oder böse.
Oder böse, ja.
So, wir haben es also mit so einer moralischen Konnotation zu tun.
Gleichzeitig hängen die Leute an den Lippen von Jeff Bezos, dessen Tenor im
Gespräch ja eigentlich lautet,
ich kenne dieses Buch im Grunde gut, das beschreibt sehr gut,
warum man mit Läden wie mit Amazon nicht weiterkommt, wenn man die Menschen
das ausleben lässt, dass sie im Grunde gut sind.
Ja.
Und ich möchte dafür werben, dass man ganz skeptisch damit umgeht,
wenn man auf einem Buchtitel schon so eine moralische Konnotation liest. Im Grunde gut.
Weil das Gegenprogramm ist nicht im Grunde schlecht, sondern beispielsweise
im Sinne von Jeff Bezos, im Grunde wollen wir erfolgreich sein. Im Grunde erfolgreich.
Und das im Grunde gut sein, steht denen ein bisschen im Wege.
Wir wollen aber auch erfolgreich sein, klar, für mich als Eigner und so weiter,
Kapitalerträger, Maschineneigner, Jeff Bezos, aber ist es nicht auch für alle ein bisschen gut?
Sollten nicht, das ist jetzt, ihr kennt alle noch die Rammstein-Diskussion mit
diesem Thomas Dingsdabums, der in der Fernsehsendung saß und meinte,
Till Lindemann macht so viele Menschen glücklich, sollten nicht ein paar junge
Frauen sich dafür opfern.
So, ja, also das ist ja so. So, und jetzt könnte man ja überlegen,
okay, bei Amazon arbeiten 600.000 Menschen, es profitieren aber 600 Millionen
davon, wie die arbeiten.
Sollte man die 600.000 ein bisschen begrenzen, im Grunde gut sein,
damit es erfolgreich für alle ist.
Alle solche Abwägungen, finde ich. Genau.
Aber diese Abwägung darf man ja genau nicht treffen. Also das ist ja dezidiert
unmoralisches Handeln.
Also das sind ja diese Debatten, dass man sagt, kann ich jetzt einen Flieger
abschießen und sagen, naja, da sterben 80 Leute, aber sonst könnte größeres
Schlimmeres passieren.
Aber würdest du jetzt jeder Managemententscheidung von Jeff Bezos sagen,
das sind mit unmoralisch dann negative, schlechte Entscheidungen,
die er trifft, weil sie der im Grunde Guthaltung widerstreben? Nein.
Ich würde die Kategorien einfach auseinanderhalten. Also genauso auch,
wie jetzt da Thomas Stein die Kategorien miteinander vermischt hat.
Also wenn, gut, der Rammstein-Fall ist eh jetzt sehr intrikat,
aber jetzt nehmen wir an,
also Autor oder es gibt ja genügend Filmemacher, wo entsprechendes bekannt ist
und auch prozessiert wurde.
Also tolle Filme gemacht hat, aber die und die vergehen am Hals.
Dann hat das eine mit dem anderen ja nichts zu tun. Das heißt.
Ich kann sagen.
Die Filme sind gut, genau, aber das will ich mal gerade trennen.
Also dann kann ich sagen, die Filme sind gut, aber der Mensch ist schlecht und
muss auch deshalb bestraft werden. Denn da kann ich nicht sagen,
naja, wer hat uns so schöne Filme geschenkt, deswegen lassen wir den Prozess mal lieber fallen.
Bei Amazon ist es anders. Da werden also Optimierungsprozesse in Gang gesetzt,
die dafür sorgen, dass die Waren schneller, billiger verkaufen.
Bei uns ankommen, also davon profitieren wir, zugleich bedeutet dieses schneller
und billiger, dass Umweltstandards oder Sozialstandards nicht eingehalten werden,
Leute wenig Lohn bekommen für ihre Arbeit, die sie verrichten,
also das Thema, was wir bei den Lieferketten haben.
Denn man kann auch sagen, was gehen mich die Kinder in Bangladesch an?
Ich finde das toll, dass ich so günstig jetzt an Mode drankomme.
Also das wäre ja eine Argumentation, die in diese Richtung geht.
Und hier würde ich erstmal sagen, also man kann auch da im Prinzip die Kategorien
erstmal auseinanderhalten,
dass innerhalb eines Unternehmens in einem kapitalistischen System das Unternehmen
möglichst profitabel sein will und es muss sich an das geltende Gesetz halten.
Wie dieses Gesetz dann gemacht ist.
Das ist Sache des Gesetzgebers, ist also nicht Jeff Bezos Angelegenheit.
Das heißt, wir sind diejenigen, die dafür sorgen müssen durch Wahlen und Protest
und so weiter, dass ein Lieferkettengesetz kommt und dann muss sich auch ein
Jeff Bezos daran halten, ob das sie behakt oder nicht.
Und deswegen glaube ich, kann man diese beiden Sachen nicht zusammenführen.
Aber es ist vollkommen klar, sobald man in einer solchen Position ist wie Jeff
Bezos oder auch auf viel geringerer Ebene,
bedeutet natürlich immer diese generelle Klassenstruktur, die wir haben.
Dass derjenige, der die Produktionsmittel besitzt und die Arbeitskräfte kauft,
versuchen will, möglichst wenig für diese zu zahlen, weshalb wir da in einem
permanenten Kampf sind.
Das ist aber genau keine Frage der Moral.
Also das ist ja auch das, was bei Marx so deutlich wird.
Also wenn Marx den Begriff Ausbeutung in den Mund nimmt, dann meint das ja nicht,
dass er sagt, das ist aber wirklich schlimm.
Also er meint damit nicht Bangladesch, also damit meint er auch.
Aber er meint damit generell jeden, der die Arbeitskraft verkaufen muss und
für einen Kapitalisten arbeitet. Das ist Ausbeutung.
Auch wenn du dann sagst, aber ich fühle mich an sich in dem Büro recht wohl,
dann hat das trotzdem Ausbeutung.
Es ist kein moralischer Begriff. Und ich glaube, das müssen wir jetzt gleich
mal ein bisschen trennen, weil Bregmann zunächst einmal eine Anthropologie,
eine philosophische Anthropologie liefert und der ganz viel widerlegt,
was ich sehr beeindruckend finde.
Und dann aber findet genau diese Vermischung statt, die du jetzt angesprochen hast.
Also Jeff Bezos macht eine Entscheidung, die sorgt dafür, dass wir schneller
an Waren kommen, aber wir haben dafür auch sehr viele Arbeiter,
die keine hohen Sozialstandards haben.
Und er beschreibt ja dann Unternehmen, wo das anders ist.
Und genau da werde ich skeptisch bei dem, was Bregmann ausführt.
Also zu diesen Fragen, was darf man, sollte man zusammenführen oder nicht zusammen betrachten?
Hier fällt es einfach zusammen. Es sind zwei Seiten einer Medaille.
Also der Unternehmenserfolg von Amazon, der nicht nur für Jeff Bezos und alle
Aktienbesitzer und so weiter sich auszahlt, sondern für die Gesellschaft insgesamt.
Und dann die konkreten Umstände beispielsweise der Mitarbeiter,
die da so drangsaliert werden mit Zeiterfassung und so weiter und so fort.
Man kriegt es nur analytisch getrennt, aber nicht faktisch.
Was für mich dann wieder bedeutet, die richtige Einflugschneise,
wenn man hier sagen will, ich will aber moralisch sagen,
wir brauchen es eigentlich besser, ist das Plädoyer für Politik,
die sich nämlich genau in dieses zwingende Zusammengehörigkeitsverhältnis einmischt.
Und sagt, wir irritieren jetzt in beide Seiten.
Also wir geben sowohl dem Kapitaleigner Vorschriften und Korridore,
innerhalb der er sich verhalten darf und wenn nicht, geht er ins Gefängnis.
Und gleichzeitig Arbeitsschutzrechte und so weiter und so fort.
Das muss dann organisiert werden. Man kann aber nicht einfach,
das unterstelle ich nachher dem Bregmann so ein bisschen am Text.
Anfang mit, na wir betrachten mal nur den Menschen und sagen,
aber der ist eigentlich gut, während wir gleichzeitig argumentieren,
aber eigentlich ist er ein sozialer Mensch, deswegen ist er ja gut,
aber die Gesellschaft ist zu groß,
als dass man sich jedem Einzelnen die ganze Zeit ganz überzeugt gut gegenüber
verhalten kann und so weiter.
Sondern irgendwo, und das ist diese Lehre hier von Jeff Bezos,
irgendwo müssen Effektivitätsgewinne eingeholt werden.
Irgendwo müssen Synergien greifen und zwar auch auf Kosten. Die kosten einfach irgendwas.
Wenn ich mir mehr Zeit nehme für Recherche, verliere ich Zeit.
Wenn ich schneller entscheide, bin ich zwar schneller zu Potte gekommen,
aber vielleicht bin ich in eine falsche Entscheidung getroffen.
Also wir haben es immer mit Abwägungen zu tun, die aus einer Beobachterposition,
muss man dann klären, gut und schlecht bewertet werden kann.
Aber wir kommen aus dieser, ich beobachte von hier aus und treffe ein Urteil, gut oder schlecht.
Aus dieser Reflexion, von wo aus man das beobachtet, kommt man nicht raus.
Und ich finde das schon problematisch, wenn man auf den Titel einfach schreibt,
im Grunde gut. Ja, weil dann hat man sich einfach unreflektiert irgendwo platziert
und sagt, ich bin ein Mensch und sage, eigentlich sind wir gut und der Leser
ist auch ein Mensch und er sagt dann, ah, der hat recht.
Ja, also der andere Mensch, der hat recht. Und wie raffiniert oder nicht es
dann im Text ist, klären wir zum Abschluss hier.
Es gibt in diesem Gespräch, weshalb ich das auch in Länge empfehle,
jetzt Hinweise, die ich absolut teile von Jeff Bezos, wie man eine gemeinsame,
gute Entscheidung trifft.
Und es sind ganz, ganz einfache Kniffe.
Es ist wirklich überraschend einfach. Ich konnte es selbst zuerst nicht glauben,
aber aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich sagen, macht es so wie Jeff Bezos.
Es führt wirklich alle weiter, individuell und kollektiv.
Man trifft bessere Entscheidungen und fühlt sich besser dabei und der Einzelne lernt auch noch etwas.
Wir steigen aber mit dem Problemzuschnitt ein. Was ist das Problem,
gegen das wir hier vorrangig angehen müssen?
Du machst diese langformatigen Dinge und lesen Bücher ist eine langformatige
Sache und wir alle machen mehr,
wenn du, wenn etwas einfach ist, machen wir mehr davon und wenn du Geräte machst, weißt du,
dass wir um ein bisschen, wir tragen in unserem Koffer ein Handy und eine der
Dinge, die das Handy macht, für die meiste Teil ist es ein Aufmerksamkeitsgerät,
weil die meisten der Dinge, die wir auf unserem Handy shorten our attention spans.
And I'm not even going to say we know for sure that that's bad,
but I do think it's happening. It's one of the ways we're co-evolving with that tool.
But I think it's important to spend some of your time and some of your life
doing long attention span things.
So, längere Aufmerksamkeitsspanne. Also einfach mal einen Bogen spannen.
Ich würde ja nicht mal sagen, die Short-Form-Videos sind ein Problem,
sondern diese hohe Abwechslung.
Wir lassen uns so berieseln vorhin jetzt passiert das und drei Sekunden später
schon was anderes und so weiter. Wie kriegt man da wieder Konzentration rein?
Einfach mal den Salon abonnieren.
Zum Beispiel einfach den Salon abonnieren, da reden wir zwei Stunden über ein
Buch und dann schreiben uns trotzdem viele, dass sie das Buch nochmal selber
lesen wollen, als ob sie uns nicht vertrauen in unserem Urteil.
Naja, es geht ja schon darum, dass man sich selbst auch Meinungen bildet.
Also wie kriegt man die Konzentration zurück und zwar zu den Problemen,
unter der Bedingung von Unsicherheit trotzdem eine relativ für alle kluge Entscheidung zu treffen.
Und wie Jeff Bezos bei Amazon Meeting gestaltet hat, finde ich vorbildhaft.
Ich kann mir eigentlich gar kein Szenario vorstellen, in dem das nicht ein Meeting besser macht.
Hall we for 30 minutes we sit there
silently together in the meeting and read
notes in the margins and then
we then we discuss and the
reason by the way we do study you could say I would like everybody to read these
memos in advance but the problem is people don't have time to do that and they
end up coming to the meeting having only skimmed the memo or maybe not read
it at all and they're trying to catch up and also bluffing like they were in college.
Man reduziert den Gegenstand, über den man entscheiden will,
auf eine Textgrundlage.
Und diese Textgrundlage liegt zum Anfang dieses Meetings vor und wird dann erst vor Ort gelesen.
Gelesen. Niemand kann einfach kommen und sagen, ja, ihr habt es gelesen,
wir können anfangen, sondern nein, es wird gemeinsam gelesen.
Und ich empfehle das für wirklich jede Vereinsvorstandssitzung.
Jeder hat seine Zuständigkeit inhaltlich, schreibt also seinen Bericht,
statt ihn mündlich vorzutragen und dann der Schriftführer schickt drei Wochen später ein Protokoll.
Nein, das Protokoll ist zu Anfang der Sitzung fertig und,
Jeder liest es, notiert sich Einwände und dann werden die Einwände durchgegangen
anhand der bestehenden Textgrundlage.
Das macht wirklich alles besser. Überall.
Es wäre auch ein schönes Talkshow-Format. Man beginnt, liest 20 Minuten einen Text vor.
Alle Anwesenden dort, die diskutieren, haben den Text vor sich.
Es geht um das Bürgergeld.
Man wird da über Truth, über die Wahrheit aufgeklärt, wie das eigentlich mit
dem Bürgergeld sich verhält.
Und dann gibt es sicherlich noch ein paar strittige Punkte und auf Grundlage
dieses Memos kann man dann diskutieren, aber nicht so Sätze wie,
ich kann bald mein Unternehmen dicht machen, wenn das Bürgergeld noch weiter steigt.
Das braucht man dann gar nicht mehr haben, weil das sieht das Memo nicht vor.
Unsinn sieht das Memo nicht vor. Und dann könnte man tatsächlich eine intelligente Sendung machen. Ja.
Und die beginnt nicht mit einem Eingangsstatement, nicht mit die ersten 10 Minuten
gehören Ihnen, Herr Merz, oder wie auch immer, sondern mit einer für alle gleichen Textgrundlage.
Und das ist ganz wichtig.
Du musst nicht anfangen jetzt mit PowerPoint oder sowas, sondern es ist die Textgrundlage.
Designed to persuade. It's kind
of a sales tool. And internally the last thing you want to do is sell.
You want to, again, you're truth-seeking. You're trying to find truth.
And the other problem with PowerPoint is it's easy for the author and hard for the audience.
And a memo is the opposite. It's hard to write a six-page memo.
A good six-page memo might take two weeks to write. You have to write it. You have to rewrite it.
You have to edit it. You have to talk to people about it. Sie müssen es dir
in den Hosen schlagen, du schreibst es wieder, es kann zwei Wochen dauern,
also der Autor, es ist wirklich ein sehr schwieriger Job, aber für den Publikum ist es viel besser.
So, also einer steht im Feuer, denn einer hat es geschrieben.
Das kann natürlich durchrotieren, es ist nach Zuständigkeiten geregelt, wie auch immer.
Wir haben ja dieses Buch von Reed Hastings gelesen, der die Management-Methoden
von Netflix aufgeschlüsselt hat, wo es ja auch hieß, naja, Hierarchie gilt ja
nicht, sondern wir sagen, du bist verantwortlich für das Projekt,
zieh dir dein Team zusammen, egal was die vorher und wo gemacht haben.
Die haben natürlich mehr so dieses projektbezogene, alle Ressourcen gehen jetzt
auf diesen Film oder wie auch immer und so.
Da lässt es sich natürlich noch einfacher machen, einfach zu sagen,
ja, du bist jetzt der Autor des Textes, damit bist du sozusagen verantwortlich
für alles, was jetzt passiert.
Nimm dir ruhig mal zwei Wochen Zeit, um das vorzubereiten. Und es ist jetzt
Lex Friedman, der so spontan einfach ein bisschen vor sich hin redet,
wo ich sage, ja genau, das ist das Prinzip, was dann greift.
Was fühlt sich an, wenn du ein Buch geschrieben hast und dann sitzt du da und
alle lesen dein Buch? Ich denke, es ist meistens furchtbar. Ja.
Vielleicht in einer guten Weise? Ich denke, es ist furchtbar in einer produktiven Weise.
Aber ich denke, es ist meistens eine sehr nervigere Erfahrung.
Ist es eine Kunst, Wissenschaft, die Schrift der sechs-Page-Memo?
Oder nur Schrift in general?
Es muss wirklich ein echter Memo sein.
Paragraphs have topic sentences, verbs and nouns. That's the other problem with
PowerPoint is they're often just bullet points.
And you can hide a lot of sloppy thinking behind bullet points.
When you have to write in complete sentences with narrative structure,
it's really hard to hide sloppy thinking.
Das ist im Prinzip der Bachmann-Preis, den er da ständig veranstaltet.
Dort ist es ja auch so, dass der Auto da ist.
Performance-Komponente wieder. Ja.
Da wird noch, genau, da wird der Text noch vorgelesen, aber eigentlich sitzen
dann auch alle so da und der Autor muss dann über sich ergehen lassen,
was die anderen dazu sagen.
Ich glaube auch, dass er sehr recht hat mit diesen PowerPoint-Sachen,
dass man da ja solche halbfertigen Gedanken schnell mal dazu schreibt und dann geht man das so durch.
Also diese additive Struktur der PowerPoint-Präsentationen gefallen mir ohnehin
nie, wenn es nicht zu einem zusammenhängenden Gedanken kommt,
sondern man eigentlich nur sagt, ja und dann gibt es noch das und das und das
und das und alle nicken das auch so mit ab, ja, ja, haben wir auch mal gehört,
wir lesen es auch noch mal gerade da, dann muss es ja bestimmt stimmen,
wenn es dann noch mal an die Wand projiziert ist und das war es dann.
Ich glaube auch, dass diese Autorschaft, die hier entsteht und auch diese starke
Subjektivität bei all der Fakten, die da rein müssen des Autors, dass das etwas ist,
was auch grundsätzlich im Schwinden begriffen ist,
wo alles nur noch in Form von Teamwork entstehen soll.
Ich glaube sehr auch an die Subjektivität des Einzelnen.
Mhm.
Also, ich fand, als ich das so gehört habe und dann vor allem Lex Friedman so
sagt, oh Mann, das muss ja gruselig sein, da zu sitzen, während alle um einen
herum im Raum schweigen, aber den eigenen Text gerade lesen.
Und du kennst es ja auch, man schreibt so Bücher und so weiter,
man hat so Texte, die werden irgendwo gelesen und es ist einem ziemlich egal.
Aber wenn einer vor einem steht und einfach mal Seite 33 kurz liest, ist das was anderes.
Also da greifen einfach so Disziplinierungsmethoden, die hier nochmal strapaziert
werden, denn jemand sitzt da und alle wissen, die zwei Wochen Arbeit von ihm
mündeten jetzt in diesen Bericht.
Wir lesen ihn jetzt alle, wir befragen ihn danach, er muss danach die Sitzung leiten.
Gleichzeitig reagiert man auf den Text so, dass man sagt, aber in zwei Wochen
bin ich ja dran mit der Textgrundlage und so weiter und so fort.
Selten, also kann ich mir vorstellen, es gibt kaum eine Situation,
in der externe Faktoren wie eine Hierarchie oder eine Autorität oder was auch
immer so ausgehebelt werden,
um einfach eine Grundlage zu legen für ein dann ja doch Gespräch am Ende.
Aber es ist diese Textgrundlage. Und dass Jeff Bezos die größten Clouds der
Welt erfindet, um die Leute aus unmittelbarer Anwesenheit herauszunehmen und
trotzdem produktiv zu machen.
Also man bucht sich irgendeinem Clickworker auf der anderen Seite der Welt, wie auch immer.
Alles wurde virtualisiert. Das ganze Amazon-Ding besteht ja nur daraus,
einfach zu verschleiern. Ja, das haben jetzt Kinder in Bangladesch hergestellt
und dann wurde es von China aus hierher gebracht und nichts davon kriegt man mehr mit.
So, man hat auf einen Button geklickt und es taucht einfach an der Haustür auf.
Alles wird verschleiert.
Und selbst so ein Verschleierungskünstler wie Jeff Bezos...
Sagt, nee, am Ende ist die Textgrundlage. Wenn du wirklich vorwärtskommen willst,
Textgrundlage oder vergiss es.
Komm hier nicht mit PowerPoint und so weiter und so fort. Das finde ich ehrlicherweise
ein ganz starkes, wichtiges Statement von ihm, dass man das hier mal so ganz
deutlich hört. Es ist die Textgrundlage.
Ja, die Textgrundlage, das ist auch die perfekte Überleitung, um in den Salon zu gehen.
Wie schon angekündigt, wir lesen im Grunde gut von Rutger Bregmann Und ich habe
den Eindruck, wir werden darüber viel diskutieren, nach allem,
was ich jetzt schon herausgehört habe bei dir.
Ich werde außerdem ein Buch vorstellen der US-amerikanischen Autorin Sigrid
Nunez, das heißt Die Verletzlichen.
Ein sehr interessantes Buch entstanden während der Corona-Lockdowns.
Es ist also in gewisser Weise auch ein Corona-Buch, aber sehr viel mehr als das.
Es hat mich doch sehr beeindruckt. Dann die Frage, warum Klasse zählt.
Sie wird beantwortet von Eric Ollen Wright.
Sein Resümee zur Klassentheorie ist bei Surkamp erschienen.
Außerdem sprechen wir über diese große Studie, dass die Männer immer konservativer
werden, die Frauen hingegen immer toleranter, also die jungen Frauen und jungen Männer.
Da gibt es einen Artikel in der Financial Times und wir haben es häufig beklagt,
was ist eigentlich mit den Männern, die nicht kämpfen wollen in der Ukraine,
warum werden die eigentlich nicht mal mit Porträts bedacht, da würde man doch
mal gerne ein bisschen mehr wissen und tatsächlich sind jetzt fast zeitgleich
Porträts erschienen dieser Männer,
einmal in der Süddeutschen Zeitung und einmal in der Zeit und das sehen wir uns auch an.
Ich steuere bei, im Sinne einer Textgrundlage hat sich Mark Schiritz und Anne
Meyer gefragt, Bürgergeld, 5,4 Millionen Menschen, Überschrift,
was machen die eigentlich?
Und dann hat man einfach mal bei den Statistikämtern nachgeguckt und nachgefragt
und das hier aufgeschrieben, also Textgrundlage, wo fliegt das Bürgergeld eigentlich hin?
Außerdem ist die Vogue-Autorin Radhika Zed, die in London arbeitet,
irgendwann entnervt aus dem öffentlichen Nahverkehr ausgestiegen.
Busse fahren unpünktlich, Züge sind zu voll. Ich gehe jetzt zur Arbeit.
Jeden Tag geht und zurück.
Wie verändert das ihr Leben? Das ist für uns natürlich interessant.
Dann der Spiegel hat derzeit mehrere sehr interessante Artikel zum Thema Krebs.
Und Krebstherapien und so weiter und so fort. Wir schauen uns den an,
in dem die Neuerungen von Biontech begutachtet werden.
Es sind derzeit, und es gab es so nicht vor Corona,
plötzlich gab es mRNA-Impftechnologie und jetzt gibt es 29 laufende Studien
für neue Krebstherapien auf dieser medizinischen Basis, allein von Biontech.
Also da geht es richtig zur Sache. Wir lesen das Buch Defekte Visionen von Alexander Thiele,
der sich die gängigen europäischen Visionen vorstellt oder uns sie nochmal vorstellt
und sich fragt, was fehlten da eigentlich?
Und das war's.
Wunderbar. Und wir können ankündigen, dass wir im Salon nun endlich bekannt
geben, wie man unser Sommer-Event buchen kann.
Es wird dann für alle ganz einfach sein, sich dort im Saalplan Tickets zu buchen.
Das werden wir dann im Salon bekannt geben. Und außerdem werden wir einen Termin
vorschlagen, an dem wir in Frankfurt in die Oper gehen, einen Tag vor einem Live-Salon.
Wer sich also dem dann anschließen will, kann das auch tun. Auch da werden wir
das Datum bekannt geben. Das läuft aber dann nicht über uns, das Ticketing.
Das ist dann einfach über die Oper Frankfurt. Wir freuen uns aber dann,
wenn wir uns dort vorher, nachher und währenddessen in der Pause sehen können.
Jetzt musst du noch schnell verraten, wie wir in den Salon kommen,
für alle, die das interessiert.
Bitte neue20er.de aufrufen im Browser eurer Wahl.
Dort auf den goldenen Button unserer Wahl klicken.
Dann bei Steady ein Account anlegen und den Salon buchen und dann...
Podcatcher der eigenen Wahl wiederum, den höchst individuellen RSS-Feed abonnieren.
Man bekommt alles, Kapitelmarken, wann wird welcher Text besprochen.
Wir werden bestimmt auch mal die Transkripte da einpflegen.
Die sind natürlich jetzt im Podcast Player noch nicht so richtig drin,
aber Apple macht jetzt eigene Transkripte. Also man wird den Salon auch nachlesen können.
Apple wird es als erstes einbauen. Wir haben ja für die reguläre Folge eigene
Transkripte, die wir auf der Webseite
zeigen. Also man kriegt einen ganz vollständigen Podcast im Salon.
Man kann alternativ aber auch, wenn man nicht Steady-Kunde werden möchte,
bei Patreon, wenn man da schon einen Account hat, aber nur dann, oder bei Apple,
wenn man auf einem iPhone-Podcast hört und die Podcast-eigene App von Apple
benutzt, die Podcasts heißt, dann ist die Salonausgabe da einfach im normalen
Feed unseres Podcasts eingepflegt.
Dann kann man einfach auf Abonnieren klicken, aber kostet einen Euro mehr pro
Monat, pro Ausgabe, als wenn man bei Steady für 2,50 Euro bucht.
Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auf diese Weise unseren Podcast unterstützt und sehen
uns dann gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.